[Norvig] So here we have a test for 1 player, and I've chosen the straight flush.
I could have chosen anything.
I say when the straight flush plays solitaire, it wins.
Here I've chosen a list with 1 straight flush and 99 full houses,
and I say when 99 full houses play a straight flush, the straight flush wins.
You may not know this notation, these types of operators in Python.
We can take a list and multiply it by a number, and that just says
repeat that list that many times.
So 99 times a 1 element list is a 99 element list all with the same element,
and then we can add 2 lists together, and that just says concatenate them.
So this 1 element joins in with these 99 elements to make a 100 element list.
This is far from a complete test suite.
We would really want much more complete coverage of tests.
Poker, we have 9 different rankings of the hands.
We would want to have at least 1 for each of those,
so there would have to be at least 9 tests and probably many more tests than that
before we had real confidence that we got it right,
but at least we got a start and we have some simple sanity tests within our test suite.